thank you for coming I will not be
offended if you won't listen to this
talk and welcome their workshop itself
so feel free to start hacking okay a
little bit about me so I've been doing
NFP for a while now I've been doing an
LP 8 Yahoo Yahoo Mail at AT&T Microsoft
did some machine learning currently I'm
leading the data science for best
practice in best projects basically do
NLP on legal contracts and all of the
examples that you're going to see today
are legal documents for from this reason
ok this is our agenda for today first
we're going to talk about NFP in general
then we'll dig into world vectors and
why are them useful then we talk about
neural networks this will be the subject
of this workshop and finally we'll talk
about our data set Google color
configuration and how to get things
actually working and I remind you all
that this is a prize winning competition
so code as long as you have to and
submit the the best model will be
awarded what are the best prizes
no-mind Leo will share with you later ok
so NLP like most machine learning a
fields can be divided into supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
unsupervised learning are mainly tasks
like clustering topic modeling in which
have a lot of documents and I don't know
what they're about what I want to
cluster them together it's pretty useful
in information context military context
also to identify languages flanks
another pretty common a unsupervised ask
is this text generation I have a chat
bot and I want to generate an answer any
anyone I've heard about the GMP to
Fiasco generating pack News so fake news
another example of
next generation in a supervised way we
will be focusing on supervised learning
and anyone here has been through the
previous workshop on classifications
okay so not a lot the common supervised
tasks our classification named entity
recognition which will be which will be
the subject of this talk and sentiment
analysis and machine translation can be
seen as either supervised and
unsupervised because there's more than
one way to translate the sentence
depends who you ask so a brief overview
of supervised NLP tasks the first one
and by far the most common one is text
classification in which I have a lot of
documents I've trade some kind of model
and the model needs to predict what
class is the is the document it's really
important to note that I know all of the
possible classes in advance this is not
an unsupervised
I have someone who labelled the data and
I know the grunt work for HM rachel
document for those who are interested in
texas if occasion you should follow this
link for previous tech certification
workshop in which we classify legal
documents what a surprise
into the recurrent into the contract
type this is an example data point we
have disagreement and we need to
classify it into one of those six types
and a single there's also videos
available for the previous workshop in
either way follow these two links for
more details sentiment analysis another
very important supervised learning task
one might think of sentiment analysis as
a special case of classification because
i have three classes whether the
sentiment is positive negative or
natural neutral
however it's a bit more complicated than
then then simple classification and
let's have a look at these comments for
the movie from the ayat' these
I'm to be comments or the movies Scott
Pilgrim vs. the world we actually got a
pretty pretty high ranking on IMDB the
first the first comment is actually
pretty simple to classify I have
indicated words like Awesomeness
good bad it reminds us of classic desk
specification
however sentiment analysis requires a
decent amount of domain knowledge for
example if I see this current
achievement unlocked one needs to know
that this specific movie is about
computer games and that achievement
locks is positive in the context of
computer games and these things are
pretty hard to model and the most
difficult aspect of sentiment analysis
is sarcasm so sarcastic reviews are
pretty fun to read but they're really
hard to analyze even pro-human riddle
Scott Pilgrim vs. my lamp we all know
that this is a negative review but for a
model to learn that maybe tomorrow we'll
have a movie about lamps that if should
have really positive implications
positive Association for this world so
sarcasm is actually the main issue in
sentiment analysis and the less
supervised the learning task they wanted
to be which will be the focus of this
talk is named MVP of ignition or for
short NER in classic named entity
recognition I have a clause or shorter
text snippet I have a predefined set of
entities for example person organization
location and the model needs to find the
entities within the text for example
just my sauce is a person queue by the
location okay the tasks day any our task
for today would be a little bit
different we will try to predict the
style of a text whether it's bold
italics underline etc but the same idea
holds okay
if you haven't guessed so far NLP and
natural language understanding in
general pretty shitty at the moment and
as everyone heard about the Turing test
great so all of you yeah people decided
that it's a bit too too early to talk
about the Turing test we are nowhere
near the amount of intelligence that
require to actually fool a person so the
Vino grad scheme was invented the
vinaigrette scheme can be thought of as
a multi choice questionnaire for during
tests meaning I have this sentence the
trophy wouldn't see wouldn't fit in the
suitcase
because it is too big and the question
is what is it possible answer would be
it's roughly the suitcase
it cannot know both of them capella now
it's enough to change one world here
from big to small and the answer
completely changes meaning that the
model has to know some kind of a world
knowledge that they thought that a
trophy fits in a suitcase in order to
figure out the correct answer if that
isn't hard enough NLP is even harder in
Hebrew so now everyone talks about the
whole vision so this is what Benjamin
Netanyahu tweeted after now after Nessa
won the Eurovision net at capella a
little bit of autonomy Netta you're real
cow that was a translation now the
people are the people at being translate
know know what they're doing the problem
is not with the algorithm it's actually
with the language what happened here is
that capella was both as Hezbollah
[Music]
it's harder than English and it causes
this kind of artifacts another example
bono hospital or no hospital we don't
have puncture we don't have none of the
vowels now if we could we actually
cannot know from the text so we need a
lot more context in order to do things
that are actually trivial in English or
Spanish by the way it's a rule of thumb
the more common language the more
colonialist conquered language lands and
more foreigners speak a language the
easier it is to parse languages get
simplified as foreigners speak it so
languages like English and Spanish are
relatively easy to pass while languages
like a ton of Slovenian or Hebrew normal
effects are harder to pass okay so this
was our intro to NLP now we're going to
talk about generating world vectors or
token vectors from the textual content
so let's start with discussing what is
the world I can take my entire text and
just split it by whitespace or
punctuation but what would I do with
world like with web addresses
obviously w double w is not a valid
world what about phrases like bestseller
rest in peace r is not the world is not
the world so tokenization might be an
issue in this world soft we ignore it
completely but you can assume that smart
organization it in place another
potential issue our phrases phrases like
new york this is in contrast to the UCL
a--
state of the art the words by this by
themself don't convey the same the same
meaning of information sometimes we
wanted to unite them into one it is
single world meaning new york the single
token
also the opposite holds words like
overrated can be written in a single
world maybe I want to split it into oval
and rated you can think about languages
like German or Finnish in which lengthen
words can be arbitrarily long so
splitting by whitespace is not always
the right thing to do
also what like pancake probably I
wouldn't want to split pancake and even
more ancient poets like manicure mano is
hand in Spanish cure is a cure it
wouldn't make much sense to split it so
also things to consider another thing
that being done a lot of times to reduce
the size of the vocabulary also known as
stemming stemming is essentially
ignoring removing the prefixes and
plavix that form a world so if I have a
world like visualization I remove the B
and the realization and I get serious as
a hoot world it is not the same concept
as root in Semitic languages like Hebrew
but it is still called a root world okay
so after we decided how we're going to
tokenize and stem and define what the
token of the world is our next logical
phase is to decide what set of words we
actually care about was what is the
value vocabulary for us to consider
there are two techniques one is actually
to filter by frequency so we're moving
very common words like V of where as in
contracts because they don't convey
information and on the other hand of the
spectrum I might want to remove very
rare words like people names or things
that appear once or twice in the text
typos
there's an another alternative which is
the use of dictionary it well doesn't
feel the dictionary I don't care about
we spied on you can use an SDK pretty
pretty straightforward if I follow this
process for example a sentence like this
one the lion is the biggest cat in
Tirana I might want to ignore all of the
connector words and then I get the words
lion biggest get Savannah I can get a
sense of what happening here sometimes
useful sometimes not okay so assuming
that I scan my Terra corpus and this is
not in vocabulary Amazon Apple Google
these are the only world that I care
about
one hot encoding is essentially this
negative ear just to subscribe so each
world vector would be a vet code that
has only one instance of nonzero values
the value here doesn't have to be one it
could be any other value of significant
like the frequency of the world the
inverse frequency of the world a some
kinds of property whether the world was
in a headline or starred in a other way
but still every world would have only
one instance that is not zero therefore
the name one hot encoding if you follow
this logic we can also create a vector
for the entire document just by summing
them essentially so here I have the
world the quick bottom dog jumped over
the lazy dog
so the world dog appear twice of the
other words you want and one needs to
remember that the size of this vector is
the size of the vocabulary this same
trick can also be applied to pair the
words also known as background so it
would have like the quick how many times
it appears quick run and go and so on
okay so this was one hot encoding also
known as the data world now we're going
to talk about word embeddings
to demonstrate this concept we will use
well to Veck what avec will not be the
encoding embedding that we would use in
the workshop but it's a good explained
it's a good example so as humans when we
read this sentence the capital of blank
is blank we know that the first blank is
supposed to be a state or country and
the second blank is a city hopefully a
capital city so what what effect tries
to do is to encode a word according to
its neighbors so hopefully the vector
for all of the countries will be the
same would be similar to on each other
to another and the vector for all cities
and capital cities would also be similar
this is like if you know how well to
vector actually works so don't be angry
with me
this is a simplification essentially we
try to predict the middle world the
center world according to a certain
window size for example towards before
toward after and we get some kind of
dense vector from the neural net this is
actually more accurate and this is the
result wonderful right we got a lot of
random numbers here so unlike big two
unlike big of worlds or why not encoding
the vector itself doesn't mean much so
it's like 15 ppm numbers but if I apply
cosine similarity I can find the vectors
for the words that are appearing in
similar context for example in legal
contracts I can replace customer with
client supplier customers etc which is
like super cool like all of those
vectors are pretty much the same no
presentation and what effect is complete
without mentioning this example so
another cool property of Auto vac is the
arithmetic if I take the vector of King
subtract the vector of man
an ethical one I get approximately the
vector of Queen which is super cool
and also if I subtract take the vector
dr. reduced effect of men and ethical
women I get nails by the way so just so
you know okay
so now we covered word embeddings what
avec is only one instance there are a
lot of techniques to do water bed inks
we are not focused on that because
actually it's not that important but it
will help us answer the question how
does words fit in a neural net
so essentially given a sentence of a
list of tokens each token corresponds
with an index in a huge embedding matrix
so I have a vector for you in some other
vector for love so in another vector for
a eye I concatenate all of them and fit
it to a neural net this example is
actually classification example the
targets as you see is either positive or
negative sentiment and this example is
so simple that you can implement it in
like six lines seven lines pretty easy
we faked your ass okay so in this
example we covered what is called a
fully connected neural network all of
the nodes on arrow no one's are
connected to each other the next logical
step is actually to convey some kind of
structure for example if I'm trying to
predict what is the style of the world
must this is a quote by Einstein by the
way life is requiring a bicycle to keep
your balance you must keep moving
so what predict weather must is bold
italic or normal you would assume that
must the word must refers to some words
around it it wouldn't be it's not likely
that it refers to like life
so what CNN convoluted convolutional
neural networks essentially do is they
help code it into the model and every
time we try to classify the word masked
I only look at the words before and
after it assuming that the window size
is 1 if the window size is 2 then I'm
looking towards before and after I sent
the world remind us a bit of a walk back
or Tyvek it also can be seen at the CNN
ok so here we have a neural net as you
can see the world must the prediction
for the world must does not account does
not the does not consider the input of
moving but when I try to predict this
type of the world Cape then I move the
sliding window one step down and now I
ignore the world you and moving on for
the entire string so this was like the
fastest way to describe what CNN does
and now we're going to talk about a very
useful concept called Allanon recurrent
neural network so essentially this is
the first model that actually tries to
maintain state what is going on without
this without behind the scenes that I
feed sequentially world after world and
there's Intel and mechanisms that is
being learned what we need to remember
or forget for each world assuming that I
fed the entire sentence some of the
information is important and some is not
and hopefully this Iranian model is
going to update its state accordingly so
let's see how it happens in in real life
and feeling the world you must keep your
data to the same model again and again I
get some kind of internal state I feed
that internal state into a neuron
networks it could be fully connected or
any other network we don't really care
and this neural network is supposed to
predict the class in our case where it's
bold italic etc later styling ok so
this is a good point to stop in
comparative in the two so in theory the
Alan n could remember dependencies from
the beginning of the document so in
theory Alan is supposed to be superior
to CNN that only the only account for a
certain amount of world before and after
however the sequential nature of the
Alan ends makes them harder to Train and
it takes more time so there's no clear
winner and sometimes then other nights
work better sometimes TN ends there's no
where the dude is still out front on
this one okay so so far we covered the
two models that apply to our problem now
we're going to talk that less and talk
about this workshop hopefully you all
clone the repo and you have to have
Python 3.6 on your computer and
everything in your follow the
instructions listed on the website the
data needs to be in the data folder
either in Google Drive on your hard disk
do not extract it it's like I think to
jjigae at least to [ __ ] bite so
twelve gigabytes
Finnick so don't the code can read the
data zipped we very warmly recommend you
highly recommend to use Google code net
collab and not use your own machines
unless you have GPUs because it would be
like 10 times faster okay so in order to
use Google collab upload it to co-op
notebooks slash the name of the repo in
your own Google Drive okay
we recommend not to download the data
and upload it because it's a waste of
time you can just right-click the data
and gray
I think it's make a copy or create a
copy over there a copy to my drive and
it will save you some time
after you clone the repo uploaded it to
Google Cloud Google Drive and copy to
the data zip Nadel you can just turn the
notebooks by right-clicking it open with
collaboratory so ok so the question was
which notebooks we have three notebooks
over there demonstrating the two models
that we covered CNN lmn and another one
called by lsdm meaning bi-directional
rmn in which we try to a train from both
sides we can me read the sentence from
the start to end and from the enter
start but this one uses pi touch wo
familiar
go ahead and after you're done training
and tweaking your model we have a little
boat after all don't forget this is a
contest submission would be ranked
according to line level accuracy let's
have a look at this this hypothetical
submission so this is the right
prediction
this is bold in bold and this is
underlined in underline and let's say
that the submission was this is bald and
this is under at the end this is correct
the line level accuracy is 50% right
because this is correct and we don't
care if you make one one mistake here
then we disqualified entire the entire
sentence so this is how the submission
submissions are ranked and we have a
little boat at this link which will
update live as you post the submission
you will see how you rank against it
against each other
the winners will get leo
[Music]
so what he said and at 9 p.m. we'll be
announcing the winners one less thing if
you have any issues any questions we
have a pretty large team of Mentos
Mentos please leave your hand any one of
them any one of them does any people
living and should be able to answer any
query that you might have and in one
last note we have we try to support
local startups here we have Dean and
guide demon guy created a notebook
demonstrating the use of this basically
this use case in their system Jegs hub I
pronounce it correctly they will also
help you work with the problem and it
will give them a chance to see out of
other systems back up so let's get
hacking